GIVEN HIS TRACK RECORD, AS PETER
MENTIONED, "JESSE WATTERS
PRIMETIME" DOESN'T BELIEVE HE IS
GOING TO SAY ANYTHING DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT HE USUALLY SAYS ABOUT
GUNS AND CRIME TONIGHT.
IF HISTORY IS ANY INDICATION,
HE'S GOING TO ATTACK THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND SAY DEER DON'T
WEAR KEVLAR VESTS.
>> NO ONE NEEDS TO HAVE A WEAPON
THAT CAN FIRE 30, 40, 50, 100
ROUNDS UNLESS YOU THINK A DEER
IS WEARING KEVLAR VESTS.
>> THINK ABOUT THE SHOOTINGS.
MANY 100 ROUNDS.
A WEAPON OF WAR.
>> NO AMENDMENT, NO AMENDMENT TO
THE CONSTITUTION IS ABSOLUTE.
>> I'M F. I'M ELECTED EITHER I'M
COMING FOR YOU AND GUN
MANUFACTURERS I'M GOING TO TAKE
YOU ON.
>> TO GUN OWNERS OUT THERE WHO
SAY WELL, A BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
GOING TO COME FOR MY GUNS.
>> BINGO, YOU ARE RIGHT IF YOU
ON ASSAULT WEAPON.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THEY
SHOULD BE ILLEGAL, PERIOD.
>> Jesse: WE DON'T EXPECT TO
HEAR MUCH ABOUT TONIGHT IS
VIOLENCE IN AMERICA'S INNER
CITIES.
MOST OF THE MASS SHOOTINGS,
WHICH HAVE TAKEN PLACE, MASS
SHOOTINGS ARE DEFINED AS
SHOOTINGS WHERE E. WHERE FOUR OR
MORE PEOPLE ARE SHOT AT A TIME
TAKE PLACE WITH HANDGUNS IN
URBAN AMERICA.
THE YEAR HAS ALREADY BEEN BLOODY
WITH HOMICIDES ALREADY ON PACE
TO TOP LAST YEAR'S HIGHS IN MANY
CITIES AND THE SUMMER HASN'T
EVEN STARTED YET.
MOST OF THEM YOU WILL NEVER HEAR
ABOUT THESE MASS SHOOTINGS.
THEY DON'T FIT THE MEDIA'S
NARRATIVE.
ACCORDING TO THE FBI'S LATEST
DATA, IN 2020, THERE WERE MORE
THAN 8,000 MURDERS USING
HANDGUNS.
BUT FOR SOME REASON JOE BIDEN
WON'T TALK ABOUT THAT.
THE GANG SHOOTING AT EACH OTHER
IN THE SOUTH SIDE OF CHICAGO
AREN'T USING AR-15s.
THE GUNS THEY ARE USING ARE HOT
GUNS.
CRIMINALS DON'T FOLLOW THE LAW.
CHICAGO HAS THE STRICTEST GUN
LAWS IN THE COUNTRY BUT IT'S THE
MURDER CAPITAL OF THE COUNTRY.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A SECOND.
47 PEOPLE WERE SHOT JUST THIS
LAST WEEKEND THERE.
>> THIS IS THE SECOND MASS
SHOOTING OF THE WEEKEND.
CHICAGO POLICE SAY AT LEAST SIX
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLED.
>> Jesse: BUT BIDEN DIDN'T CARE.
IF HE DID, HE WOULD TALK ABOUT
IT AND NEITHER DOES CHICAGO'S
MAYOR.
WHEN A REPORTER POINTED OUT THAT
THE CITY'S VIOLENT REP IS
SCARING AWAY TOURISTS SHE
COMPLETELY LOST IT.
>> NONSENSE THAT YOU ARE SPEWING
THAT TOURISTS AREN'T COMING TO
OUR CITY, ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS
WALK UP AND DOWN MICHIGAN.
>> NO, SIR, NO, SIR, NO, SIR.
YOU WILL STOP SPEAKING.
>> MICHIGAN AVENUE.
>> YOU ARE FULL OF CRAP.
THAT'S THE NICEST THING I WILL
SAY.
I WILL NOT LET YOU SPOIL THIS
MOMENT.
>> Jesse: IT WOULD BE NICE IF
SHE GOT MAD AT THE GANGS
SLAUGHTERING INNOCENT KIDS ON
HER STREETS INSTEAD OF THE
REPORTERS ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT
IT.
IT'S NOT JUST CHICAGO THOUGH,
REMEMBER, PHILADELPHIA'S D.A.
LARRY KRASNER HE SAID THE CITY
DOESN'T HAVE A CRIME PROBLEM.
>> THERE IS NOT A BIG SPIKE IN
CRIME AND IT'S NOT TRUE.
THERE IS ALSO NOT A BIG SPIKE IN
VIOLENT CRIME.
NEITHER ONE OF THESE THINGS IS
TRUE.
WE DON'T HAVE A CRISIS OF
LAWLESSNESS.
WE DON'T HAVE A CRISIS OF CRIME.
WE DON'T HAVE A CRISIS OF
VIOLENCE.
>> Jesse: FAST FORWARD TO THIS
WEEKEND, OVER 40 PEOPLE WERE
SHOT IN PHILLY.
MY HOMETOWN.
SOUNDS LIKE A CRISIS TO ME,
LARRY.
PRETENDING VIOLENCE ISN'T REAL
LEAVES MORE INNOCENT PEOPLE
DEAD.
AND TIGHTENING GUN LAWS JUST
MEANS THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO CAN
GET GUNS ARE CRIMINALS.
YOU NEED COMMON SENSE SOLUTIONS.
NOT THE SAME OLD IDEAS THAT HAVE
BEEN MAKING THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
MORE DANGEROUS YEAR AFTER YEAR.
IS BIDEN READY TO LOOK AT THE
FACTS AND PROTECT AMERICANS?
I HAVE LAID OUT ON THE AIR
SPECIFIC POLICIES TO HARDEN
SCHOOLS AND BEEF UP RED FLAG
LAWS.
THESE ARE EASY, COMMON SENSE
SOLUTIONS.
ALL AMERICANS CAN AGREE ON.
WE HAVE ALSO DISCUSSED ON THE
SHOW THE NEED TO KEEP VIOLENT
CRIMINALS OFF THE STREETS.
AND WE HAVE ALSO DISCUSSED THE
ATTACK ON MASCULINITY IN
AMERICA, HOW THE TOXIC INTERNET
AND COVID SHUT DOWNS ARE
POLLUTING PEOPLE'S MINDS.
THE POLITICIANS JUST NEED TO GET
IT TOGETHER.